man who knows percentages and math and
is also a big fan of the of football
happens to be the general manager of the
houston rockets kind enough to join us
before
tip off uh four and a half hours before
a very big pivotal game five
uh joining us from the orlando bubble as
it is known
is daryl murray gm houston rockets how
are you sir
rich thanks for having me on do you want
to do you want to answer the poll
question first
you want to answer that one which oh man
i just i i don't know enough about the
nfl but the patriots sound low
i don't ever count bill bill at checkout
and that
organization is incredible their track
record
yeah so okay so you go patriots on that
one i don't count them out either but uh
i just you know tb12 is just down the
i-4 corridor for you right now um
where where what is bubble life like
what's it been how
have you been you've been there since
the for the duration have you been there
since the start
yeah whole whole time uh a lot of
a lot of a lot of stress a lot
you know um you know i think we're all
all focused on the championship but in
the midst of that
obviously very important things going on
in the world and
it's been definitely a time you'll
attend you'll tell your grandkids about
it's it's it's been interesting the nba
has done an incredible job
setting this up but uh you know every
day
you're also hearing about terrible news
out in the out in the world so
we got to keep our focus on the on the
important thing well i mean and
and again that's what kenny the jet
smith was talking about
uh earl you know in the previous uh hour
daryl
is that the it's it weighs on everybody
that you're inside
um you know a sealed spot happens to be
a place
called disney world and that um that
players
uh are beginning to chafe about not
being
able to be out and part of the social
justice scene right now
um obviously there's a job to do but are
you seeing that from your players too
you you hearing that yeah i think uh
yeah i was born in wisconsin so this one
hit
even more close to home um
yeah no i think everyone's feeling that
we're in you know sort of this
uh you know we're all in our different
bubbles whether it be
our news bubble or an actual
you know pandemic bubble uh we're all in
these bubbles but
you know right now we're even more in
one and it just feels like you lose
connection
to the most important things and uh
you know i uh but at the same time
you know we're all we we're all we all
have a job to do so i mean these this
these tensions have been going on for
uh for everybody uh down here well i
know that um again you've got a lot of
uh on your plate and you've got a job to
do and i don't mean to add
information man to your your uh
you're hyphenate but i'll i'll attempt
it right now i mean there is word
that we're hearing about that the
celtics and raptors might not play their
game tomorrow because of what's going on
out in the world and that they feel like
this would be their way
of joining the social justice protest
within the bubble using uh game one of
the eastern conference semifinals as a
method
to communicate uh their protest or
do you think that might happen are you
hearing that might happen down
well we're a player driven league i
think for good reason um
i think one thing uh you know both the
the nba players union and and the league
and commissioner silver has
you know put the players front and
center i think that's what led to such a
great
restart here and i think the players are
going to lead again
on this and you know whatever
is whatever whatever's decided they're
gonna
they're gonna have full support just you
know just like you know
it's very hard for um
myself i you know i can't walk in the
shoes of some of the people who are
um you know getting killed getting
you know systematically targeted
but i can say i support them i can say
black lives matter
and whatever the players come up with i
know
will be fully behind daryl morrell
houston rockets general manager here on
the rich eisen show
as for the actual competition let's get
into it right now
what can you tell me about russell
westbrook's readiness for
today yeah this morning we got some
positive and that you know he
uh you know we had to see how he reacted
to
practice yesterday this morning uh that
went
positive um still not
a hundred percent we don't know what
will happen he's gonna
you know give it a uh give it a go and
warm-ups before the game and then it'll
be a game
time decision with the medical staff and
and russell and uh and we'll see
obviously a big
big impact um you know whether he plays
or not and
and we'll see where his body's at would
you determine imperative that he plays
today
down no i mean i i think we've shown
obviously they're a very good team and
uh credit to
you know coach donovan and the players
they've they made the adjustments that
were needed after those first two games
to to really battle us
and win two two close ones um so i think
uh we're very evenly matched they're
very tough
tough team but we we can beat them
without russell obviously if he's back
that's a big positive for us
okay so then what what do you let's just
say um
what you've seen for the first two games
over the next two games
just the ball not going in
i i know i know it sounds very simple
that you've got to score the basketball
to use the phrase but what do you
you know what's your keen eye looking at
the difference between the first two and
the next two
of this series here obviously yeah every
possession is analyzed to the end
uh by coaches and myself while we're
down here i think it's pretty
straightforward
we think we have a very good game plan
against them
offensively and defensively in three of
the four games
we've executed well offensively and
three of the four games we've executed
well defensively
in game three our offense you know we
just weren't crisp
and it was a basically a tie game going
to overtime and
they did what needed to be done to win
and then last game our defense
wasn't sharp and most of practice
yesterday was to clean that up uh and it
was again
you know a one one point game in the
last minute so
uh both times you know we didn't execute
down the stretch to win it but
um but you know we we need a we need
both like games one and two we had both
sides of all click and then we won by
double digits so
we need that tonight and you know
obviously our uh
our job is to get it done now obviously
when it comes to to your world right now
you're laser focused on
on a tip of a basketball literally four
hours from now in a
pivotal and that is not just uh
overstating it um
game five to look over the steering
wheel
would be ludicrous normally but when uh
woge puts the name of your coach out on
twitter
to be of interest to indiana the day
that indiana fires its coach in nate
mcmillan it does require me to ask the
question
uh if he's available that indiana would
be interested in him what do you
how do you respond to a report like that
daryl
yeah i mean the timing was weird but uh
you know
uh mike kenton is a hell of a coach so
i'm not surprised people are interested
and you know we love mike and he loves
being here so we'll work that out and
we've already asked and answered that
we're gonna
you know meet after the season so so uh
why do you think there has been a spate
of um
firings like that uh for the the bubble
four teams they get eliminated and then
all of a sudden they make a change like
that that's the fourth time one gm and
three coaches now
we're seeing it feels not too dissimilar
to the end of season
i mean i could be wrong but i mean we're
i mean basically we're at what would
normally
be the may you know uh may time frame
in the mbas and that is when a lot of
this is announced so
i i think it's you know obviously you
don't want anyone to
be fired and but i think it's pretty
normal to have
you know two to two to two to five of
these things at the end of the season
okay and then where do you watch the
games from where are you
literally stationed i mean
the bubble you don't have many options
we got the yard we're allowed to walk in
we got a team room we got a room
um yeah albert the arena um you know i
i sometimes have tough time watching the
game live so i'll walk outside the
building
in the little area they have for us but
um
other than yeah that's that's where i'm
at no one should care where i am though
no i'm just curious about this you know
so you walk outside and there's a yard
yeah
i mean i thought i was literally insane
until i talked to jerry west and he told
me he
he doesn't watch i felt slightly more
normal i figured
you know if he's doing it he i should
copy everything he's done he's won so
many titles i
i don't mind copying him yeah his logo
is bigger in the bubble i'll tell you
that i mean that thing is
monster large jerry west has gotten
larger but the way you describe it and
you say you know
crazy it does sound like cuckoo's nest
they give you a yard and you can walk in
and
the only thing missing is the chief you
know i mean yeah no
we could uh we could do so you know we
could use the chief sometimes just uh
but you know that you're gonna you're
gonna chase away some audience they're
not
talking about a 1970s film but yeah
obviously hey
[Music]
you know i make my staff watch old
movies so i can make references and have
them fake laugh at them
it's great did you just reveal your
management skills
is that do you really do that i really
do that yeah we'll host the
movie night and and uh every couple
months and
i make them watch airplane and
caddyshack wow big lebowski
and that otherwise otherwise they won't
i at least need them to fake laugh for
my jokes so i'm not totally depressed
all day so
i need them to understand what i'm
talking about so i i mean you're talking
about
what millennials on your staff that here
this is caddyshack this guy's name
this this is ted knight and ted knight
used to be in mary tyler moore and you
should know who ted knight is like
literally that's a daryl murray moment
for the right 100 i'm a little i'm i'm
an airplane lebowski
yeah all that exactly exactly and yeah
we have a very young staff i mean i'm
sure
you're the same when the you've uh
you've got such a successful show i'm
sure you got
a lot of young young talent coming in i
appreciate that the youngest is chris
brockman who just turned 40 across the
way from me and he
always makes me feel old when i'm like
talking about movies like network which
by the way is required viewing for
anybody in the communication business
you know i mean big time for sure you
know what and
this is why we get along daryl uh before
i let you go you're my own you're you're
like my
you're you're my end here i haven't
spoken to a coach yet but i'll bring
this up because we brought this up uh on
the program is this just yesterday how
are we closing yeah
yesterday did the coaches get together
and make a conscientious decision to
dress down for the bubble did they
literally all get together and say that
do you know yeah yeah that uh i think
normally a suit is required
but uh yeah they you know i think the
coaches union
you know went with uh went with the
polos as
i i said it should i know durant like
the dressing down he mentioned that i i
thought they should go with like the
baseball strategy and wear a uniform
that would add something that's the fun
to the bubble so
that had like a jackie moon feel to it
if they ever did something like that
um but so they did actually get together
and say hey
when we when we go to the bubble just
leave the suits was it a dry cleaning
uh concern like seriously i'm wondering
this stuff i mean
it's a condom call i don't think they
actually physically got together
but yeah i believe the coaches union
which is a strong union
i do believe it was discussed that
they're at their meetings
on zoom and uh yeah so that's my
understanding
i mean you'd probably have to ask mike
and tony or someone but that's what i
understand that's what i'd see i knew
you'd you'd at least
have uh your ear to the ground that's
why you you you're a general manager
of note in uh in the nba thanks for the
call daryl again i know you got a big
game coming up shortly and um
and i really appreciate it thank you for
the call you take care of it yeah thanks
very much congrats on peacock
thanks bud pretty cool stuff but we'll
chat again real soon we'll chat again
real soon that's you bet that's
darryl murray hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here